was brought to buenos aires from the
northern province of chaco when she was
a child
she's a member of the calm indigenous
community her family was escaping
poverty she says discrimination has been
part of
for my children it's difficult to accept
that they call us indians or they leave
us aside we are not animals they cannot
come and tell us what to do they cannot
kill us when they want
last month in argentina some survivors
and descendants of the com and mokoi
people took part in an unprecedented
trial of a case that goes back nearly a
century ago
in 1924 hundreds of members of the
ethnic groups were killed by ranchers
and security forces for protesting for
better working conditions in cotton
fields in napalpi in the province of
chaco
on thursday a judge acknowledged the
complicity of the argentine state in the
killings and ordered a series of
measures to assist the communities today
the trial for the massacre in napalpi
shows the serious abuses that indigenous
communities suffered in this country
only one million of the 45 million
people in argentina consider themselves
descendants of the original indigenous
groups most of them live in poverty and
continue to fight for survival
pacqua
lives not far away from napalpinchaco
he's also a member of the calm
indigenous community he says his people
have to struggle for food and work and
remembers when the police beat him and
accused him of stealing beef two years
ago his granddaughter juliana was there
they accused me of having beef in my
house but i had nothing it was a lie the
police make mistakes and blame us but
those who do things are never detained
testimonies of police abuse are frequent
among indigenous communities
this video went viral during the
pandemic when security forces entered a
neighborhood in the province of chaco
and beat the men and women inside the
house
is a prosecutor in the province he says
the trial of napalm is important to
fight the discrimination that continues
to exist today
institutional violence against
indigenous groups is very common there
is racism among security forces and not
all the cases are investigated and
there's impunity
one of the objectives the trial has to
do with is putting an end to racism in
the state and among security forces
argentina has long prided itself of a
european heritage one that often
neglected and persecuted indigenous
groups
the trial of nepal peace a step to
revise history and give indigenous
communities the place they have been
denied for too long
teresa